[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos en el espacio porque el
telescopio hubble de la nasa descubrió
la estrella individual más lejana de la
que se tenga registro detectó la luz de
este cuerpo celeste que existió en los
primeros mil millones de años después
del nacimiento del universo
hemos estado trabajando bajo la
suposición de que la luz que estamos
viendo es sólo de una estrella masiva y
con esa suposición resulta que tendría
que tener al menos 50 veces la masa del
sol así que es realmente una estrella
grande realmente masiva la estrella
recién detectada está tan lejos que
suele usar 212 mil 900 millones de años
en llegar a nuestro planeta
previamente objetos vistos a una
distancia tan grande habían sido cúmulos
de estrellas dentro de galaxias
primitivas ahora el descubrimiento de
esta estrella que fue bautizada eran dos
que significa estrella de la mañana
promete abrir una era que hasta el
momento ha sido inexplorado de formación
estelar
continuamos en eeuu para conocer la
historia de crescent un calado bicornes
que se encuentra en el zoológico de
tampa y que padecía cáncer de piel tenía
un tumor ubicado en la base del cráneo
donde emerge un cuerno hueco y también
afectaba a la parte superior de su pico
mediante una cirugía esta parte fue
reemplazada con tecnología de impresión
3d biocompatible
históricamente este padecimiento no
tenía un gran pronóstico por lo que con
frecuencia cuando se diagnostica en
calados es lamentablemente una sentencia
de muerte y no porque el cáncer se mueve
a otras partes del cuerpo no entrar en
la linfa los nódulos los pulmones o algo
por el estilo pero es muy invasivo
localmente por lo tanto consume su pico
y eso significa que no pueden comer
entonces su calidad de vida su horrible
y por ello con frecuencia son
sacrificados antes de que el cáncer los
maten
usando sus imágenes en 3-d pudieron
crear esta guía quirúrgica en 3-d que
encaja justo sobre el borde aquí y
entonces lo que hace es esencialmente
una plantilla y los cirujanos
exactamente donde necesitan eliminar
esta porción por ser un laboratorio 3d
bio médico privado diseño del casco 3d
personalizado así como una guía
quirúrgica impresa también en 3-d
después de extirpar el tumor del ave los
cirujanos usaron acrílico dental para
sellar el artefacto en el pico de
crescent antes de unirlo permanentemente
con tornillos de titanio present que
tiene 25 años y mide 90 centímetros se
recuperó casi de inmediato y ahora está
mejorando con su nuevo pico
seguimos hablando de impresión 3d y nos
desplazamos hasta la ciudad de austin en
texas donde se está construyendo el
mayor vecindario impreso en esta
tecnología se trata de un proyecto de la
empresa emergente icon technology y la
casa modelo que ya está lista cuenta con
2000 metros cuadrados la edificación
presenta una variedad de paredes curvas
mezcladas con zonas construidas en
madera de abeto
lo que están viendo hoy es la primera de
nuestra serie de casas llamada casa cero
escogimos este momento para mostrarle al
mundo esta innovadora tecnología que es
posible gracias a la impresión 3d es una
de las cosas que más nos enorgullece y
que tiene que pasar cuando vemos la
construcción de casas a gran escala es
la capacidad de entregar las rápidamente
y para este proyecto específicamente
pudimos construir la estructura de las
paredes y empresa en 3-d en unos 10 días
se prevé que el proyecto esté terminado
para este verano y se trata de
edificaciones sustentables que se
construyen en 10 días y que tienen
costos bajos comparados con lo que
significaría un proyecto similar con
técnicas tradicional
creo que un par de cosas que emociona a
la gente que interactúa con una casa
empresa en 3-d por primera vez es que no
pusimos ni una sola línea recta en esta
casa a propósito mientras caminas por
este pasillo es como si te abrazara se
ondula y te encuentra donde tú estés y
te lleva hacia donde la casa quiere que
estés te da libertad y flexibilidad
otra cosa que queremos mostrar es la
naturaleza variada de los materiales así
es cómo esperas que se vea el sistema 3d
impreso de paredes pero queríamos
mostrar que se puede ver así ponerle
baldosas y quisimos elevar la
experiencia de zonas que no siempre son
hermosas y finalizamos en israel porque
la empresa emergente brain space probará
su casco que estudia datos de la
actividad cerebral en tres de los cuatro
astronautas que integran la tripulación
de la misión acción space la primera que
en un viaje privado lleva a humanos a la
estación espacial internacional
este sistema no depende de ningún
técnico no requiere ninguna preparación
ni ningún proceso especial para llevarlo
puesto basta con hacer clic en un botón
y listo ya puedes empezar a medir la
actividad cerebral green
captura es enviar nuestros auriculares a
la estación espacial internacional no es
re sencillo pero el proceso nos demostró
que si el casco funciona será el más
eficiente y robusto a hardware la trata
de una misión de 10 días y de acuerdo
con los responsables de este proyecto
este experimento se convierte en algo
sumamente importante porque hasta el
momento se han recopilado datos sobre la
frecuencia cardíaca la resistencia de la
piel la masa muscular y otras
informaciones de los astronautas en el
espacio pero no sobre la actividad
cerebral los astronautas que usarán el
casco realizarán una serie de tareas
durante 20 minutos al día durante los
cuales los datos se cargarán en un
computador portátil se han completado
estudios similares con estas tareas en
la tierra por lo que después de la
misión brain space comparar a los datos
del electroencefalograma para ver las
diferencias
en la actividad cerebral en el espacio y
nuestra visión en brain space es
proporcionar un acceso fácil a la mente
humana lo que nos gustaría lograr
nuestra visión es crear un lenguaje del
cerebro y permitir que médicos
investigadores e incluso desarrolladores
de aplicaciones utilicen este lenguaje y
crear productos y servicios basados en
el cerebro services y
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros que hay más en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]